[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
March 16th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
after several extensions student loan
payments are expected to resume later
this year but some borrowers already
struggling with their personal finances
could find it difficult to make ends
meet Wall Street Journal reporter Gabe
Rubin joins us to discuss hey Gabe thank
you very much for being here pleasure to
be with you so cave catch us up for a
moment where do things stand where the
litigation surrounding President Biden's
student loan forgiveness proposal so a
couple of weeks ago the Supreme Court
heard arguments in the case and the
decision is expected by the end of the
Court's term late in June so in the
months between now and then we're not
really likely to know anything from the
courts or get any signals that they're
going to rule one way or another alright
so when the Supreme Court decides what
happens then so they will either rule
that President Biden's plan can go
forward or they will strike it down as
unconstitutional so payments would
restart about 60 days after the court
issues its ruling or the Biden
Administration implements the program
and just a reminder that program M would
cancel up to twenty thousand dollars in
debt for people who make under a certain
income threshold and comply with certain
other requirements so either way around
60 days after the Supreme Court wraps up
the case people with remaining student
loans will have to start making payments
on those loans which they haven't done
or haven't been required to do since
March 2020 and the difference would be
that some people would have their entire
loan balance wiped out or would have
significantly less money to pay if the
program is allowed to go through as
opposed to if the Supreme Court strikes
it down all right so let's talk about
what this means with regard to borrowers
personal finances people of nearly all
ages have some kind of debt they're
paying off but why has the impact of
potentially resuming payments among
younger borrowers raised concerns yeah
so these are households that are really
getting squeezed by both High inflation
and Rising interest rates and we see the
shift in credit conditions being
starkist and among these younger
consumers who are less likely to have
significant savings are more likely to
have student debts and borrowers in
their 20s and 30s reached 90 days or
more delinquency on credit card debts
and auto loans at a higher rate in the
fourth quarter of 2022 than they were
before the pandemic and people in these
age groups Millennials and gen Z
consumers are accounting for more
spending in the economy which makes
sense given that they continue to get
older and account for more of the adult
population of this country so they
accounted for about 30 percent of
spending in 2021 which was up from
approximately 25 percent in 2019
according to the labor department wow so
they play an important role in the
economy and now with possibly the
repayments coming along what does all
this mean in terms of their actual
ability to resume payments yeah it
raises concerns that these younger
Americans are less likely to have the
savings to tap when their finances are
stretched and it raises the likelihood
code that they could default on some of
their loans or be late on credit cards
and face mounting debt in all sorts of
areas of their life whether that's an
auto loan credit card debts falling
behind on mortgage payments so it's
definitely a concern for a variety of
areas of the economy so are these
challenges and struggles faced by you
know Millennials and gen Z the the
younger generation of Borrowers is this
being recognized At All by people on
both sides of the student loan
forgiveness argument yeah certainly so
the Biden Administration has actually
made the higher risk of defaults coming
out of the payment pause one of their
main legal reasons for the mass student
debt cancellation program and that is
the case that they made before The
Supreme Court now on the other side
Congressional Republicans say these
payments have been paused for three
years at this point and the cost of that
Pause by not accruing interest and the
government not collecting payments have
has cost well over 150 billion dollars
so they make the point that the
continued payment pause is almost like a
mass debt cancellation program in and of
itself at its core opponents of the
masdaq cancellation program simply don't
think that the Biden Administration has
the Constitutional ability to decide
that because these borrowers may have
higher default risks then they deserve
to have all of this debt canceled and
they believe that that power really only
rests with Congress to decide whether to
do something like that whereas the Biden
Administration thinks that their
authorities under certain emergency laws
that were passed after the 9 11 attacks
are perfectly applicable in a pandemic
situation all right that's Wall Street
Journal reporter Gabe Rubin with us Gabe
thank you very much for being with us
thanks for having me and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you